so the position of ski does is not gonna
violate the ground grounding angles of
your knees so you're not going to do
that you see my knees open like toes
that's not right so I'm going to be with
that right angle and my hip is going to
be engaged in it okay who ever seen is
this right with no hip and we also seen
over hit your knees they'll be here and
you're leaning this way so if you just
wait you're gonna fall that way your
last stats is the same stance that we've
been working away so I ground I'm
finding the back foot and when I came
forward that's that's the same stance
boom boom boom boom so I can sit here
all day there's nothing there's no I'm
never going to call this where you start
leaning so your ski he's not combative
over here you see it's way this way yeah
I'm going to fall that way
they thing up over here oh it's wait
whoo go on let's go on down here boom
I'm going to do it again we'll go just
wait even a pause keep your torso over
your face like the rider on a horse stay
over the horse boom boom
okay here Todd here here hey let's do
your own thing
the question is how do I do this steps
but you're asking it without referencing
your partner you're just like I guess I
just go like that you just that's what I
get
okay so you know Here I am
alright there's this line of attack if I
just do that safe snip I did over there
I go over here
okay I cleared the line of attack but
Who am I fighting somebody over here I'm
not fighting him so your solution is
here and now you have not cleared the
line of attempt you get that
so you're confusing I know I need to be
fighting him just your intention to do
the technique makes you aim at him it's
correct but you're forgetting his Center
is a sphere so I can cut a vector
through it still through its center
without standing in front of them so the
same thing if I take if I'm if I'm
moving and I take a shot at him right I
don't go oh I don't have to be 27 target
so the way up there if there's the
centre of this body no I'm gonna aim
pulse that's gonna do its job this is an
upper thoracic shot do you get it
because it's gonna hit what's in here I
don't go like this so boom here Here I
am
here's where I am here
so watch what I watched I'm gonna give
you a tool I'm going to keep this
position and I'm going to move until
this relationship aims at him did you
get it
don't lose it don't lose it
see you changed it now you're gonna do
this so keep the relationships till it
aids in and you're off and that is where
you're going to turn save the
relationship of the ski okay keep
everything - singing head shoulders and
you're going to move till it's pointed
on him then you're going to find the
angle okay try just that
but if you just think about a little bit
you don't drop your weapon so I'm okay
and this is your mentality right now
but you are always advice to what push
through right when you're doing this
mentality this is a new term my turn
okay so don't get hurt and come off the
wall okay when I see that mentality
looks like this well we should be my
intentions skewer the hell out and end
the fight you can get it I'm not if I uh
I'm not here to dabble so let's take a
look let's strike and you're gonna do a
Japanese strike okay he goes like this
I'm not gonna do this on a deadly strike
don't try to touch it okay you're not
gonna do this stuff on jabs
so I'm jabbing just move up don't get
killed keep your keep your right the
problem is that my whole friggin body's
coming in so we'll go slow and he just
may take the range but my gonna say that
my body's not chapter now so I'm goes to
show you get on the same page as me
right he goes back right you see no
problem and that's more efficient for
him but if my whole body's come in and
he tries to go back full everything's
coming that way I'm gonna catch him
that's what's making where you're
stepping up here Fievel your little step
let's do the technique your little step
right here so here was where my scheme
was and you went six inches forward and
off to the side and that's causing this
problem
but when I ski fully I can't make that
step why
you're in deeper okay page eight
backflip coming off the ground it's too
much inertia too much momentum okay that
my balance will not be there so if you
guys remember in the weapons to you
you'll have your shooting platform when
we're static but when I ask you to
spread I have to you go I have to remind
you you're gonna have to put that foot
out to deal with in the residual inertia
right so when I do that when I do the
ski you can't you cannot put your foot
there
you understand that and in fact your
state you're gonna you're gonna cut as
hard as you can on the technique right
okay your best bet is to keep going
forward you get it forward it up the
circle not backwards and out the circle
so if you guys the only reason I'm
stopping there it's because I'm now
going to attack but if I did one attack
just run through you'd be fine
so wait up when I go this is where I'm
at now because that is where my foot has
the possibility of stopping you guys are
all trying to stop not here much loose
Bible because you're trading blows okay
do you understand dude you take a Kimmi
so my hope like that is the closest that
you'll find your athleticism can deal
with the full attention of the skeet
okay thanks man
very much so
penny for pocket touch his challenging
but only for those who still don't take
a candy but those who still think you
can be is rolling and falling that's
only a portion of it Kemeny is doing the
inside of what noggin is doing so if
naga is trying to match yunnan Armed
Forces I am trying to imagine in young
forces but I'm doing from the it from
the receiving side not the initiating
side do you understand so when he goes
right there this is energy that's coming
out to me so I don't stay here ignore it
right go resist it do you understand and
so when I'm matching you into young
forces where do i originate that
matching of the indian forces when i'm
not getting what part of my body your
center that's weird
what part of my body as you can do you
think i originated matching indian
forces in the center okay so the center
must move if your center is staying
still in space you just look here if
it's staying still in space go but you
did not do Kenny you're gonna get hurt
got it so your Center must move let's
just start there go where does it move
it moves in harmony with his forces so
his force is coming to me do you see so
there's first step go back when he
starts to go I can feel that right go I
can feel the yen - do you see the yen so
I'll follow the yen so I have an
addition
young in the drill goes then again and I
fill the end so my Center will tend to
go back down go down not stay still
boom not go down it's got to go back
down back you go faster okay let's go
[Music]
but as we go as I go on I've mentioned
it briefly the in space is as he starts
to go slowly right here's the in space
to see that the you space is not it's
not here obviously so if you were to
count if we were to counter it right
that's exactly what I would do so to
help me I'm going to do that but I'm
hookah so I cannot do that I have a
prescription to do so but I let my sword
turn here you see that and I maintain
connection once my hand has entered the
in space fully so as he starts to go I
know he's not going to hit me and I keep
connection for his training and my
training when we go down some of you are
yes
back down but you see you kept on on
here so let the sword turn
CACO misunderstanding the training
culture is getting in the way so when we
train because you have to address the
learning curve training is done
staccato like embryonic lee my turn your
turn but that can't be fighting you have
to understand that that's just because
you're learning and it's easier to learn
that way but you are going to suck in
the impurities of your assumptions that
are filling in the blanks which is adesh
you should not do you don't make a
scenario everything we do is a drill
even when it looks like there's a
beginning middle and end don't fill it
in and then you're just doing these
movements where did you do it for
because that's what I was told to do how
to use it I have no idea that's where
I'm at right now later when you
understand someone asks you how do you
use it
you'll you'll have a million in one ways
of how do you okay but right now your
mind is making a narrative we already
addressed it so my turn your turn that
we've ever said that same thing here
when I come here you are again imagining
that this is what mafia touches and iron
told you that's not machi touched
because that would be a block and
there's no blocking an Ikea that's a
nice
now beyond you're doing it wrong then if
you look at it is called macchiato
scrolling drop what's the point of the
draw check out there to check out their
Center how it's a gravitational check
I'm trying to pin but he has to do what
at the end of this narrative this little
technique even in your mind guys to take
a carrying because what's following a
ski so he can't up your pin
do you understand that so maybe you you
might think that you're gonna survive
crack you're gonna survive that right
but you know what you're super baby
protected you but you got checked out
and when I come in with that ski you're
not going to be able to take you Tim
okay so when we when we're doing the
movement okay we're doing the movement
go and I showed you I am going around
you see I I can free myself that means I
am NOT at his mercy which is the goal of
Luke and Luke is not a victim so when we
go here and he starts to drop I am not
pinned do you see I just maintain
connection on the bottom I'm in no
different estate than he is he's on top
I on the bottom that doesn't mean
anything so as he goes to ski he's a kid
Santa
I am NOT being 10 do you understand so
don't go by Shuba I'm gonna lie my scuba
I don't even have a scuba don't rely on
your tuba check your party did you feel
your feet get slamming into the ground
then you did you're not going to survive
that next strike at full speed okay you
feel your shoulders getting jerk you're
getting painted into the ground do you
understand it should be free enough for
you to come all the way around to dance
around you need me to go to the back
okay let's go